et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
mirvat rifaat aliyeva présidente de la
maison de l'azerbaïdjan à paris bonsoir
madame merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés ou soir franck papazian conte
président du conseil de coordination des
organisations arméniennes de france
bonsoir à vous monsieur merci d'être
avec nous également alors une résolution
au sénat qui n'a qu'une portée
symbolique même si on imagine vous vivez
sac à main un vrai soutien est ce que
franck papazian vous êtes est déçu ou au
contraire par le symbole peuvent
finalement tout changer en fait c'est
une vraie décision politique une tonique
qui a une portée politique puisque ne
sous-estimons pas l'existence du sénat
dans un cadre démocratique et les
représentants du sénat à une écrasante
majorité 305 sur 306 ont voté pour que
la france reconnaisse l'indépendance de
la règle belliot karabakh
ça montre bien effectivement que
l'opinion publique française la classe
politique tous courants confondus
soutient effectivement la question
d'indépendance le haut karabakh
vous savez j'ai assisté j'étais au sénat
- cet après-midi et j'ai assisté au
procès de l'azerbaïdjan tous les
sénateurs qui se sont succédé à la
tribune sans exception douze sur douze
représentant l'ensemble des forces
politiques ont fait le procès de laser
médian sur le fait que c'est bien la
cervelle gens qu'à attaquer le 27
septembre
les sénateurs ont considéré que
l'azerbaïdjan était coupable sur le fait
que l'azerbaïdjan avait violé les trois
cessez le feu
les sénateurs ont considéré que
l'intermédiaire était coupable
ce le fait que la turquie est
massivement soutenu l'azerbaïdjan dans
cette guerre les sénateurs ont considéré
que l'âge médian est coupable les turcs
y compris sur le fait que 2010 est à
dist étaient dépêchés par la turquie sur
place pour soutenir laser de l'armée
azerbaïdjanaise
c'est une preuve de culpabilité
également l'azerbaïdjan surarmés la
turquie et les djihadistes honte
effectivement gain de cause dans le haut
karabakh
vraiment bravo et je voudrais également
souligner la question des nombreux mien
varie pardonnez moi parce que c'est un
débat voilà pas par définition vous
aurez le temps de réagir pardonnez moi
encore un miroir ifat à liévin qu'est ce
que vous répondez comment vous ressentez
justement effectivement ce soutien très
massif de la part des sénateurs français
et de l'argumentaire que vient de nous
expliquer cette description en tout cas
de ce qui s'est passé au scénar cet
après midi oui lensois remercie de votre
invitation
alors je suis en tant que française j'ai
de large et la route on va dire et en
tant qu'esclave badge à l'aise je suis
extrêmement déçu de cette décision
delà du sénat de cet après midi ses
initiatives et du lobby arménien en
france ne vont pas seulement à
l'encontre du droit international mais
aussi internationaux français en effet
la souverainété de l'azerbaïdjan sur le
territoire du haut karabagh a été mainte
reprise reconnu par la communauté
internationale par la législation
internationale notamment par les quatre
résolutions du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu votée en 1993
rappelons que la france a également voté
un pouvoir de ces résolutions
aujourd'hui je parle également de près
de 1 million déplacées internes les
réfugiés hazard va gêner puisque
moi-même je suis anne déplacés internes
d'une région avoisinante et la grande
détresse de ces déplacés et réfugiés
azerbaïdjanais chassés de leur terre
natale victimes de la purification
ethnique pratiquée de façon violente et
mélodique par l'arménie dans les années
90 n'ont inquiété et nanou semble
inquiéter personnes s'étaient déplacées
réfugiées hélas n'ont jamais bénéficié
d'un tel compassion anhalt et les landes
compassionnelle de la part de la france
leurs droits humains
fondamentaux ont été bafoués pendant 30
ans où étaient ces défenseurs de droits
de l'homme ou été ou étaient les
politiciens français en arménie a
exterminé 613 personnes
la ville de rozzano en 1992
donc est ce c'est l'absence totale de la
compassion envers les victimes
azerbaïdjanaise de ce conflit
me choque violemment et je suis vraiment
très choqué vous monsieur papa besoin
vous vous avez toujours continuer
longtemps d'autres vos compatriotes de
ce n'est la désinformation en présentant
la commune et a relégué en jalles
appareils pareil pour vous on va te
répondre c'est le temps de la réponse de
parts et d'autres
en tout cas jean yves le drian lui voilà
n'est pas dans le sens du sénat parce
qu'il dit on l'a entendu tout à l'heure
si l'arménie elle même ne reconnais pas
de haut karabagh et que l'on demande à
la france de le reconnaître en étant en
même temps président du groupe de minsk
ça devient acrobatique
il ya du vrai quand même franck papazian
c'est le bon sens qui a exprimé ici
le chef de la diplomatie je ne crois pas
madame c'est pas très compliqué pour
l'arménie de reconnaître la république
du haut-karabakh pense qu'elles veulent
faire dans les jours qui viennent ça va
avancer à quoi en réalité lorsque nous
dit on doit effectivement les sénateurs
français demande à la france les
citoyens français les six cent mille
citoyens français d'origine arménienne
demande à la france de reconnaître
l'indépendance du haut-karabakh est un
acte de justice et qu'on peut compter
sur la france pays des lumières des
libertés de la démocratie pour faire
acte de justice et pour rendre justice
effectivement aux arméniens du
haut-karabakh ont vécu pendant 70 ans
sous souveraineté azéri passe comme il
le dictateur staline avait décidé
arbitrairement de donner cette région à
l'azerbaïdjan
ça ce n'est pas contestable madame en
fait est l'instrument de la diplomatie
de l'azerbaïdjan et conjugue le mensonge
à tous les modes ce qu'elle dit qu il y
a eu un million de déplacés mais enfin
il y avait 80 % d'arméniens
il y avait 20 % d'amérique s'il y avait
un million d'azéris qui ont été déplacés
à ce moment là ça veut dire les 5
million d'arméniens sur place arrêtez
avec ces mensonges
arrêtez avec la propagande de rhodes
jaloux libérer les otages que vous
détenez aujourd'hui siby les limites et
militaire que vous humilier que vous
torturer que vous utilisez comment je ne
sais pas ce que parce que votre armée
les met sur les réseaux sociaux
tout simplement et il me montre encore
une fois une preuve de culpabilité vous
essayé par tous les moyens de faire
mulot biais vous mobiliser des millions
d'euros pour le faire vous ne gagnerez
pas madame parce que le mensonge en
france et la dictature de votre
république de votre état n'ont pas droit
de cité en tout cas emmanuel macron lui
il dit voilà clairement il l'a dit il ya
trois jours le président que le haut
karabagh est est un territoire azéri
effectivement les sénateurs ne sont pas
du même avis l'on m'envoie même un
signal
avec ce vote à emmanuel macron sur le
jeu vous propose d'écouter christian
cambon président de la commission des
affaires étrangères au sénat
c'est un message que nous envoyons
effectivement à l'exécutif car le groupe
de ministres qui depuis 20 ans s'occupe
de cette affaire du haut karabagh
manifestement ne donnent pas les
résultats que l'on attendait on a quand
même été assez humiliés par les
conditions du cessez le feu
la france n'a même pas été prévenus la
question qu'on peut se poser
mireval et fatale ieva pourquoi autant
de mobilisation alors qu'un accord de
paix a été trouvé que l'exécutif
français semblent avoir effectivement
entérinée alors pour moi cette guerre
est terminée il n'y a plus de
négociations au niveau de statut du haut
karabagh depuis tant d'années la france
n'a pas fait d'efforts pour essayer de
parvenir à un accord pacifique dans leur
cas là bas maintenant que la paix est de
retour entre les deux pays
je l'inviterai
tous les perdre toutes les personnes qui
veulent que la paix soit instaurée dans
cette région du caucase et il faut
plutôt aider le peuple arménien à
reconstruire la paie également le peuple
azerbaïdjanais aussi pour reconstruire
la paix avec leurs voisins au lieu
d'inciter les arméniens en allah allah
el d'ailleurs le ministre arménien des
affaires étrangères gérard gardien
mentionnait il ya quelques jours dans
son interview il a souligné en vison
telle mentalité du gouvernement arménien
devait évoluer ne plus être dominé par
la haine et la peur envers ses voisins
il invite le gouvernement arménien de ne
plus considérer ses voisins comme ennemi
donc pour moi le l'accord signé le 9
novembre dernier était amené une chance
pour le peuple du peuple arménien du
haut karabagh également pour la
république d'arménie puisque après cet
accord il y aura des échanges avec
l'économique qui vont également aidé la
république d'arménie pour se développer
donc il faut prendre cette cet accord
comme une chance pour les deux pays
comme une chance pour rétablir la paix
et donc le droit international
thullier l'acte d'helsinki de l'eau et
c'est souligner clairement que le droit
à l'eau pour entrer dans les détails
effectivement des accords pardonnez moi
madame parce qu'à une autre actualité
importante champs ce dossier c'est
l'ambassade de la république
d'azerbaïdjan république française qui a
saisi les autorités judiciaires ont vu
d'une enquête sur je suis tes crimes de
guerre commis par des citoyens français
d'origine arménienne et non arménienne
propose de regarder ce communiqué avant
de réagir l'ambassade de la république
d'azerbaïdjan en république française a
saisi les autorités judiciaires
françaises en vue d'une enquête sur les
crimes de guerre commis par des citoyens
d'origine arménienne et nous arménienne
se revendiquant du nationalisme arménien
sur le territoire de la région du haut
karabagh dollar
public d'azerbaïdjan selon nos
informations qui ont été d'ailleurs
confirmée par les médias français
plusieurs dizaines de ces mercenaires
français d'origine arménienne et nous
emmène yens ou affiliés à l'extrême
droite se sont rendus à erevan avant
d'être acheminés sur les territoires
occupés de la république d azerbaïdjan
par les forces armées arméniennes ont
crimes de guerre dont franck papazian
une réaction je pense que en fait la
meilleure défense c'est l'attaqué que
l'ambassadeur d'intervenir en france est
vraiment gonflé parce que s'il est clair
aujourd'hui les trouver ces lasers
médian qui a utilisé des armes aux forts
relents et des âmes de sous munitions
je crois que faisons-le enquête que les
autorités internationales cache une
enquête on est tranquille là dessus mais
que ce soit pas laser vert gens qui
passent l'enquète mais qu'on est des
enquêteurs internationaux qui se rendent
sur place en toute liberté qu'ils
puissent effectivement décidé de savoir
qui a commis des crimes de guerre vous
savez dans les hôpitaux à yerevan il y a
des dizaines et des dizaines de blessés
dont on voit bien qu'ils ont été frappés
par des armes chimiques ou des armes à
sous-munitions madame connais tellement
mal son dossier que elle elle a cité
gerlibach étant en tant que ministre at
étrangères de l'arménie
c'est pas du tout le minivan des
affaires étrangères de l'arménie en
réalité dont elle connaît pas bien et
c'est d'apprendre par coeur ce qu'on lui
dit mais ça ne valait pas le cas je
crois aujourd'hui qu'il est important
également de lancer cet après midi au
sénat de nombreux sont nos sénateurs ont
demandé à la france de saisir la cpi
parce que l'azerbaïdjan s'est comporté
en véritable agresseur et à utiliser
juste ans alors les femmes mercenaires
emerson et moi je suis désolé de vous
couper mais on arrive à la fin du débat
je n'avais qu'à me laisser le mot de la
fin puisque par définition c'est un
débat je sais que vous avez beaucoup de
choses à dire tous les deux mr barry fat
alliés va très rapidement s'il vous
plaît parce qu'on il nous reste une
petite minute sur la notion de crime de
guerre d'ailleurs
deux côtés oui alors j'aimerais bien
juste précisé que les sur les
mercenaires c'est rien que monsieur
papazian n'arrête pas de souligner et
aucune preuve jusqu'à maintenant on n'a
été apportée à l'azerbaïdjan
s on ne peut pas se baser des rumeurs
pour accuser un pays dans sa je suis
désolé c'est inacceptable pour pour
l'azerbaïdjan
et quand on parle de crimes de guerre il
faut parler de centaines de civils tués
a bien déjà loin de ville de contact il
faut par de hauts parler aussi de balsa
de talent terre de cette ville martyre
il ya eu près de 100 à peu près ces
villes
moi aujourd'hui un art mini kong and
civil vous avez qui ont été touchés donc
il faut pas non plus dire des mensonges
sans arrêt et ne pas justifier vos actes
terroristes quelque part pour accusé
l'azerbaïdjan des mercenaires série
annoncée c'est totalement faux et ça n'a
jamais été accepté par l'azerbaïdjan et
ça n'a jamais été prouvé non plus merci
en tout cas république france qu'est ce
qui a effectivement signalé qu'ils
étaient tracées par la france donc je
pense que la france est un pays en état
sérieux et les pâtures merci en tout cas
à tous les deux mir ali à faire dévier
va et franck papazian d'avoir accepté ce
débat tous les deux merci